the aspect of this though that I find
really troubling is I think it goes back
a ways like I for a moment I thought
that this transgender craze was totally
new and it's taking everything by storm
it might actually upset feminism or it
might upset same-sex marriage you know
which is argues against it in some ways
right right Born This Way is very
different than I can change my entire
fluidity sex yeah the fluidity but I
think I'd like to blame all of this on
the feminists and and the reason I would
like to do that is the essential
argument of transgenderism
if one can even say there is an argument
it's a little it's a little out there is
men and women are exactly the same men
can become women women can become men so
they're it's expressed differently but
really one is the same this was the same
argument for same-sex marriage that the
union of Two Men and the union of a man
and a woman is exactly the same right
it's the exact same category and it's
the same argument of second wave
feminism that women are exactly the same
they can do every single thing just like
the men